[Music]
Christian
s
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
that y'all are here I have been coming
to the table for a little over a year
it's my first time to do this so I'm a
little anxious but that's okay because
this is family
um and we are glad that you're here I am
glad that you are here
so welcome to the table today
um the first announcement for today on
the first Sunday is that right after
church we will be going to hat Creek
um Burger Company right after the
service and this is really a great way
to get to know one another to meet some
new faces and have some connection and
it is only a few minutes down the road
in Sachse if you need directions ask one
of us I can't give it to you right now
but I can find out so
also the Kids Table volunteers are
needed and if you have a heart for
kiddos and really would be willing to
serve in the kids ministry
there is a card out on the on the tiny
little table in the hallway and you can
put your name and phone number on it and
just write kids table on there the goal
is that the people who help with kids
table would only need to serve on a
rotation about once every three weeks so
that everyone can be part of the worship
service
so that's the announcements for now and
if you just join me in prayer then we'll
start with our worship service
God we know how loving you are in the
midst of
all that is happening in this world
um
we give you thanks for your grace and
your mercy and your love
thank you for the hope that you provide
to us in the midst of tragedy
and hardship in the in the midst of the
joys that we have in our life
we give you thanks for one another
thanks for this place here at the table
and most especially thank you for your
love and your son Jesus the Christ and
it's in his name that we pray
[Music]
and I know it's vulnerable so thank you
for being
um I also just wanted to make a quick
announcement that tonight is our first
um I think calling it Community Sunday I
wish Devon and Anna were in front of me
because I thought they were the ones but
I know that she's home sick tonight but
anyways it's the first Sunday of every
month like Leslie was saying is the
night that we go to hat Creek it's also
going to be the night that we keep our
second through fifth graders I believe
in the service with us rather than them
usually transitioning into their
classroom and
um that's mainly because you've probably
heard us say up here before we really
want our kids to be incorporated into
the full life of the church and we don't
want them to be seen and not heard
um and that comes with like transitions
where we learn how to be in service with
our family where we learn how to
um for instance maybe take communion or
how to sit through a worship set and
engage with the music how to listen to
someone and take in information so
um this is going to be our very first
night to do this and our if you are in
second through fifth grade and you're in
the back can you just wave
raise your hand hey guys welcome to Big
Church
we're so glad that y'all are here
they're normally with us in the first
song and then all the kids go to
classrooms but tonight after the first
song I'll dismiss our younger kids to
their classroom as usual and those guys
will stay with their teachers in the
back or they are welcome to sit with
their parents during the service if
that's what you choose to do as a family
that is completely up to you so thank
you kids workers for your vision and the
way that you are calling us forward as a
church to help us incorporate them I
just really appreciate our kids team can
we give them a hand and just say thank
you
all transitions come with bumps in the
road so I'm sure it's going to be it's
going to be a transition but we want to
walk this out together and do family
life and do Church Life as a community
as a whole Community from the top to the
bottom so thank you guys for being
patient and working with us as we learn
to do this better
um all right can you guys go ahead and
stand we're going to get started with
Reza Hallelujah Josh and Joe are going
to lead us in that song and if this is
your first time I see a couple faces
I've never seen before so I'm just going
to take this moment to introduce the
people who are up here with me I'm Mindy
and this is Josh and Joe Brock and then
Jesse's back here on drums this week and
Josh Tilford is on keys and we are
normal people just like you so please
join in with us as we sing We are not
wanting this to be a performance but an
all play experience where we get to
bring our full self into a worship
environment where we experience Jesus
together as a community so we invite you
guys please sing along if you want to if
you want to open your hands if you want
to close your eyes sit through the music
but you are fully invited into this
space your whole story your whole life
all right so let's go let's get going
[Music]
I raise a Hallelujah
in the presence of my enemies
[Music]
I raise a Hallelujah
louder than the unbelief
I raise the Hallelujah
[Music]
my weapon is a melody
[Applause]
[Music]
Hallelujah
Heaven comes to fight for me
[Music]
ashes hope will arise
with everything inside of me
[Applause]
[Music]
I raise a Hallelujah
I will watch The Darkness me
[Music]
[Applause]
Hallelujah
[Music]
[Applause]
hope will arise
[Music]
death is defeated the king is alive
sing a little louder
think a little louder
I'll sing a little louder
[Music]
in the presence of my enemies
louder than me
take this
storm
[Music]
Hallelujah
all right
all right you young children our
preschoolers and kindergarteners can go
to this classroom on my left your raise
and big kids if you arrived late you'll
be staying with your parents or with
your kids
[Music]
big thank you too
I know who else is serving with her but
thank you guys
Whitney thank you Whitney
all right we're going to move into the
prayers of the people now again if this
is your first time this is a an
opportunity as a community that we take
each week to make space for the things
that we carry into this room together
our burdens the things that are on your
heart and mind that are heavy we want to
help you carry them and we believe that
God also is with you in those Low Places
with you
on the on the journey so we want to make
space to name them together we're going
to read this prayer aloud all together
and then we'll leave space for you to
say a name or a situation that you're
carrying on your heart if you speak that
out you are more than welcome to do so
you're invited to do so if you're online
you can leave that in the comments and
we will read well and then we'll close
out with the prayer at the end
would you guys join me in reading this
for this city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
the addresses
those who were impacted by the shooting
[Music]
thank you
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light healing and
Hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
thank you
[Music]
you unravel me
with the melody
you surround me with the Sun
of
deliverance from my
enemies
[Music]
let's sing that again
I'm no longer a Slave To Fear
who I am a child who God
[Music]
from my mother's womb you have chosen me
love has called my name
I've been born again
into your family
your blood flows through my veins
[Music]
Who I Am a Child
I'm no longer
fear
[Music]
[Applause]
I am a child oh god let's sing that
again I'm no longer I'm no longer
Slave To Fear
Who I Am a Child of God
[Music]
who I am I am a child of God
foreign
[Music]
excuse me so I could stare and sing I am
a child of God
split the seasons
[Music]
I am
a child
guide
no longer
slave to feel
no I am a child oh God
I'm no longer
[Music]
Slave To Fear
I am a child of God
[Music]
it's God we are fully yours
we are fully known
and loved
thank you God for meeting us right here
in this moment
in our ears to your voice guide
let us hear you speak to us
thank you
Here's My Heart Lord
hears my heart Lord
speak words
[Music]
Here's My Heart Lord
thank you
the word is true
cause I am found
I am yours
[Music]
if I can breathe
I am healed
I am free
[Applause]
there's My Heart Lord
here's my heart
[Music]
Lord
speak what is true cause I am proud
I am yours I am
loved I made pure I have life I can
breathe
I am healed I am free
[Music]
you are
you are indoors
[Music]
foreign
speak word is true
[Music]
I am
proud I am
a pure
I have life
I can free
I am here I am
because
always true
[Music]
you are great
is true
[Music]
yeah
speak what is true
[Music]
yes God we open ourselves up to your
voice
even that small whisper inside of us
calls us forward
beyond our Brokenness
beyond our limited perspective
the voice that calls us towards hope
towards a new life
towards Resurrection
thank you for not giving up on us
for walking each step with us
you are a faithful and good God
we love you
we give this time to you
thank you for the space to connect and
be your children alongside each other
it's in your name we pray all these
things
amen
would you guys turn to the people around
you and welcome them make them feel at
home and then Brett will get us started
with our message
well Grace and peace
it is so good to be with you all
um my name is Brett I'm the pastor here
am I on am I coming through is my green
light on yeah I'm on
um so uh yeah it's just it's so so good
to be with you so good and uh that is
especially true um for anyone here who
is new
um thank you for being with us in this
space and also a warm welcome uh to
those joining us online
um but also uh our second through fifth
sixth graders whatever it is uh we love
you all lots and I'll try not to bore
you with a sermon too much I'll try to
keep the energy up okay I'll do my best
um but uh yeah it is it's just really
good to to be with you all so
um before I jumped in I wanted to
um speak uh to the shooting that
happened in Allen
um if you saw my my Facebook post
earlier today this is like near and dear
to my heart because I grew up in Allen
um until I was in junior high then we
moved to to Lucas
um but so I've been here in this area my
whole life but specifically Alan and so
I have lots of memories there I have
memories at that outlet mall as um any
of you do too you know what's it's like
right there on Highway 75 and
um lots of folks go there and um
I was you know it's it's one of those
situations it just stirs up so many
feelings I don't know about you but I
was like sort of all over the place like
um some fear you know like when things
come so close to home you know it's one
thing for like the kind of abstract that
City out there in that other place you
know it's another thing when it comes
real close um the fear can get more real
um there can also be a sense of um I
think kind of deep frustration and
um almost powerlessness like what is the
plan here you know like um it's we're in
such a strange moment
um kind of politically where you know a
majority of Americans
um support some um certain things around
gun control and such
um but because of the political gridlock
um nothing gets done and it's just it's
it's a very um it's a difficult place to
be and so I I wanted to name
um kind of two things one if you're
looking for something like I want to do
something
um one way you can go to TX
gunsense.org and um it's a way there's a
page there where you can just fill out
and send basically a message to your
Senator to certain Congress folks like
it's it's people kind of related to
Texas and broader
um where you can um just you know let
your voice be heard kind of in that way
um so you're you know I would encourage
you to do that um as well as though I
wanted to name you know more on the kind
of um personal
um emotional side you know our mission
here at the table is to shift a
generation from reactionary to Visionary
to the person and work of Jesus Christ
and when I think of um reactionary it's
all of those emotions that aren't bad
they're not bad emotions
um but it it's the emotions and things
we feel that can
um push us or lead us to a place where
we're not responding but we are just
reacting it's that sense of Despair that
Fury that um
uh hopelessness like those kinds of
feelings that kind of eat us up and we
start to just kind of circle in our own
emotional you know world and um kind of
can spiral and so I think this is where
like you hear us I mean it's almost Ad
nauseam if you've been here for months
or years at the table you know I'm
always talking about
um spiritual practices things we can do
and I'm talking it's like it can be all
so many things
um in fact a lot of the heart of the
message tonight is how God leads you on
the path that's right for you and there
are certain um spiritual
um disciplines and practices you can
engage that will get your heart and mind
in the right place a place where you can
be not reactionary but Visionary and
help our world and that is what we need
like we need a church who is not
reactionary but Visionary right so it's
not to say by not reaction I don't mean
just you know does nothing and just sits
at home quietly and does spiritual
disciplines that's not what I mean right
the whole point is get our hearts and
Minds right so that God can use us right
like that's the call so
um
yeah so that's that's just I don't know
that's my heart around that and um and
so if you're here tonight and your
heart's heavy
um as we'll read in a moment maybe your
heart feels troubled um just know you're
not alone you're not alone and um we're
there with you and we're praying and
seeking
um
peace
and healing for our world so
um all right with that in mind I want to
shift over to the the series that we're
in uh right now we're in the season of
Easter tide which for those unfamiliar
we tend to think of Easter as like it's
one day it's Easter yay and then that's
over and then we move on
um but it gets a little out of balance
because if you were here for us in the
days leading up to Easter you know we
did the season of Lent which is like 40
days of spiritual preparation and so
that can get very out of balance where
it's like 40 days of like let's focus in
and you know God search my heart and you
know all that and then it's sort of like
all right one day to celebrate okay back
to the grindstone you know so I I do
like having this kind of 40-day season
of celebration of um reflecting for an
extended amount of time on the the
resurrection of Jesus and so that's kind
of what we're what we're doing in this
in this series so um with that in mind
the title of my message is specific to
tonight is the path the path I want to
read this is from John chapter 14.
verses one through six and it's a very
famous passage especially verse six as
we get there many of you will recognize
it so this is Christ speaking and um
he's just finished up in the previous
chapter chapter 13. a lot of kind of not
so good news
um to the disciples about how they're
going to abandon him and betray him and
it's going to go real badly and so
um so then he says this opens chapter 14
with these words do not let your hearts
be troubled
you believe in God
believe also in me
for my father's house has many rooms if
that were not so would I have told you
that I'm going there to prepare a place
for you
and if I go and prepare a place for you
I will come back and take you to be with
me that you also may be where I am
that's going to be a key phrase for us
tonight because it's the idea of
relationship and connection as we'll get
into one of the I think dangers with
this passage is that we when we read it
we're kind of reading it we're thinking
like Oh Heaven I'll go to heaven you
know which I do think is true I do think
he's talking about sort of the life to
come but that often gets us thinking
only about that and not abiding in
deepest relationship
today right so that you may be where I
am verse 4 You Know the Way to the place
where I'm going
Thomas said to him Lord we don't know
where you are going so how can we know
the way Jesus answered I am the way and
the truth and the life
no one comes to the father except
through me
so
um where I want to focus tonight is more
on the stuff I just named around kind of
heavenly Hereafter and how our Focus
kind of goes there and
um and I want to talk um kind of go some
different directions on that um however
I do want to address verse six because I
think it can stick in a lot of our minds
there's um I would say a certain kind of
common interpretation of this where
Jesus basically starts to um or at least
the way it's presented what we hear is
Jesus is like the great bouncer of
Heaven
in other words
he's he's not making a way
he's doing what
he's like blocking the way he's standing
in the way like uh-uh what you thought
you're getting in here oh
no no no no one comes to the father
except through me and that means no one
comes the father right like that's
always how we start to hear it is like
almost like she's standing there wrong
beliefs wrong theology no no no no
certainly the wrong religious tradition
oh so wrong no right instead of the
mindset of like in other words
um we hear a very strong Christian
exclusivism here like Jesus is blocking
the way and making sure only the right
folks get in
which is usually like the people we
think should get in and you know
um instead of what I would call a
Christian inclusivism
which would be
um Jesus is opening up away Jesus is
making a way now
um I you know in this I mean I'm a
Christian so I do I agree with Jesus he
is the way right so if you're like well
you're saying I don't know all the ways
are the same way or no I'm saying Jesus
is the way but again he's just not the
great bouncer of Heaven saying
I think he is like in essence you might
say if there is any saving to be doing
if there is any healing or restoring to
be happening and I mean just look at our
world there's a lot of saving and
healing and restoring that needs to be
happening I believe it is Jesus who is
doing it
but but his his heart is I mean if you
just read the gospels his heart is
precisely to make that way for people to
open it up
so now I've given you two sermons that
are not my sermon
um so let's get into it where I actually
want to go tonight
um so I want to start just kind of
walking through this passage let's come
back to verse one do not let your hearts
be troubled I love that Jesus is so
sensitive to the disciples
um like so I thought like he knows where
they are emotionally and he's tuning in
and he's comforting them I think we
often I don't know if we always think of
Jesus as like sensitive and thoughtful
and tuned in to people
um but he absolutely is like he is that
way do not let your hearts be troubled
um and then at which point he kind of
launches into his whole explanation you
know hey it's okay like I'm going
basically to make a way I'm going to
prepare a place for you like if that
weren't so why would I have said that's
what I'm doing like I I am in essence um
we might um kind of hear that you know
Jesus is he came from the father he's
returning to the father and he's not
going back alone
right he's taking people with him so
he's kind of comforting them and talking
about how he's making this way and uh
leave it though to uh we many of us know
him as doubting Thomas which is sort of
this um I don't know it's almost like a
slam on Thomas
um but uh because of a another situation
um but I love I do I love Thomas I think
he was like the honest disciple that's
kind of how I think of Thomas and it's
it's fascinating that he's the one who
speaks up here did you catch that part
in uh verse five Thomas said to him Lord
actually
we have no idea where you're going or
what you're talking about
what is this way and how on Earth can we
know the way but it's so interesting
what Jesus says he doesn't say like oh
I'm so sorry okay let me make it clear
he's like he basically kind of
um uh names like Thomas Thomas like have
you been with me this whole time like
don't you know
I am the way
don't you know I am the truth the life
like it's connection to me Thomas like
that's that's what it's all about
and um I think in essence he's asking
like if you know me if you trust me and
you trust my heart for you and all
people just trust I'm making a way I'm
making oh wait I know sometimes we come
through these doors and we feel like
we're not on the way
and um like Jesus would want nothing to
do with us like he's abandoned us he's
rejected us we're not good enough holy
enough whatever it is and and I just
want to name
um if you've ever been in that place
where Thomas is
Jesus has a heart for you
and he's saying don't worry I am the way
I'm making a way for you right in
essence
um I think of it as like our future
is Resurrection Life
and Hope
if um
one of the things I I love or about this
idea of our future being Resurrection
Life and hope and Union with God
connection with God is that it becomes
kind of as I alluded to earlier it
becomes very relevant for today
and not just as I mentioned a Heavenly
Hereafter right because when we read
this as like oh he's going to prepare a
room I guess that's like some sort of
mansion for me to live in when I go to
heaven
um right it sort of this whole passage
becomes about later and in essence the
whole Christian Life
really becomes about later
right maybe you've had that kind of
theology at some point in your journey
where it's sort of like what am I doing
now I don't know I'm just saved and
I just be saved you know and I guess try
to get other people saved and then I'll
go to heaven one day and then my life
will begin
right like can you see where this kind
of gets twisted because I'm not trying
to reject heaven or say like there's no
Heaven no no I do think but the idea is
we walk in deepest Union in connection
with God Here and Now
and then what do we do in the life to
come we just keep right on walking
we just keep right on living and of
course I mean it's different it's like
more but it's but we get tastes of it
here and now
and um
I think like that I think should it like
uplift and encourage and give a deep
meaning to this moment into this life it
shouldn't drain it of meaning where it's
like well this is all just terrible
um but I guess I can't wait for heaven
like if I think of kind of a danger of
of certain interpretations of a passage
like this even a danger of my Easter
message if you were here for that um I
talked about how your your future is
Resurrection Life and hope and Union
with god um your future is
um not the grave your future is not dust
and Ashes and hopelessness and tragedy
and despair that is not your future no
your future is Resurrection Life and
hope and but can you hear how a certain
ear what people could hear in that is
like oh so one day I'll go to heaven
and it's sort of like
okay yes
um but I'm talking about like yes that
is your future but it's a future that
sort of reaches back from the future and
grabs you right now and says I want you
to live connected to God right now now
um
I could I'm sort of imagining you know
um kind of how this could be hitting
some of you and uh maybe I don't know
maybe it sounds like just so lofty you
know like your future is um is
resurrection life and you're gonna live
that here and now you're made for
deepest Union and connection with God
and you're like
I don't know what that is you know like
I what what are you what are you getting
at like I'm just trying not to be mean
to my dog and let my kids and hold a job
here like what is you know all this uh
this sounds very grandiose you know
um
one way to to put it is
I talk all the time maybe too much no
there's no such thing as too much the
fruit of the spirit it's like the heart
that's like my life message if I just
have myself into church Galatians 5 22
talks about
um love the fruit the results of God's
spirit in your life it's love it's Joy
it's the deepest peace it is patience
love joy peace patience kindness
goodness gentleness faithfulness
self-control and of course that's just
like a list but it could keep going you
know courage and I just keep could keep
going
um but when I think of like what human
beings are longing for
I don't think there's some radical
disconnection between what we are
longing for in our heart of hearts
and
what God promises us
but so often in our hearts like there is
a disconnection sort of like yeah like
this is what I'm longing for but I know
you know that's not gonna happen for me
so I'll just I guess I'll just go to
church try to stay on God's good side
maybe I'll get to that heaven place you
know like no no no we're made for it now
to begin to get tastes of it now
um I'm not saying your life will just
become perfect you'll never have another
struggle I don't mean that but I mean
even in the midst of of whatever hell
you could be going through
you can more and more and more sense oh
I'm not alone
I'm not alone there is a power greater
than me
right it's it's it's no longer like I've
been crucified with Christ it's no
longer I who am living just me all alone
but it's Christ now within me the Holy
Spirit lives in you a deposit of God
in you have you ever thought of that
like we just kind of throw that out
there like yeah the spirit's in you all
you know we're just gonna oh that's
that's nice nice little religious
sentiment like what does that mean God
is in you now
amen like at least one person gets it
like that right this like this I think
calls us to something
um and one way to think of it even if
you're like oh I don't know if I'm
tasting it though or feeling it or
learning this or like one way to think
of it is um
you know that your whole life here's the
good news your whole life God has been
conspiring in the best of ways
to draw you to himself
like that's what's been happening now
perhaps you haven't been very tuned into
it and maybe have been actively like
running away from it right so there is
something about saying yes to it which
is really the heart of the message as
we'll get into but but the good news is
um God is always faithful God is always
doing God's part to draw you to God's
self
um one of the more I think just tender
vulnerable beautiful passages
um from the Old Testament prophets is
Hosea chapter 11.
uh verses one through four this is like
sort of like poetry but it's like God
bearing God's soul to us
and he's he's here talking about how um
how God relates to us but the metaphor
is us as little children God's people
he's talking about Israel but it relates
to us God's people how God relates and I
wonder is this our image of God
I think this is like straight from
scripture and this is a beautiful
powerful image of God it says this when
Israel was a child oh I loved him
out of Egypt I called my son
but the more they were called the more
they went away from me right that gets
to that idea of where just because God's
calling and doesn't mean we're like yes
and amen you know it's sometimes we're
like
the more I I called the more they went
away from me they sacrificed any
mentions these are sort of idolatrous
practices but all this is sort of a
false god and they burned incense to
images you know in idols verse three but
it was I who taught Ephraim to walk look
listen to this image taking them by the
arms
ever seen a parent or a loved one do
that with like a little
a little kid I've done that before it
takes tremendous patience
uh which you would think of it's like oh
it's so cute and precious and it is it
is but they are so bad at walking you
know it's like okay we are really going
we're going slow here you know like
imagine Jose is saying that's God
that's god with you
because maybe you're like I'm trying to
be on the path towards all that stuff
you were talking about Brad you know
towards Union with God I'm trying but I
am struggling that's okay
God's Got You
got your arms
it was I who taught Ephraim to walk
taking them by the arms but they did not
realize
it was I
I yield them
I led them with cords of human kindness
with ties of love
that's the truth of God to you
Church your whole life God has been
healing you and calling you and drawing
you
with ties named love
and we've got to learn to trust just
like Thomas had to learn to trust
that Christ came from the father
and Christ is going to be faithful to
take us back home again and again that's
that impinges on today too not just in
the afterlife right I mean I mean like
right now
coming home
to Christ
I mean home to God feeling that love and
joy and peace and patience letting it
bubble up as signs of the spirit Among
Us
now this um does mean a certain amount
of surrender though this can be a
challenging thing like you might think
oh it's wonderful to be led by God and
like he's teaching me to walk the good
path you know um but there's some
challenge with it and it's it's kind of
a blow to the ego in a ways one of the
great Saints of the church Teresa of
Avila
um she put it like this she said it is
presumptuous of me to wish to choose my
path
because I cannot actually tell which
path is best for me
I must leave it to the Lord who knows me
to Lead Me by the path which is best for
me so that in all things his will may be
done
think I'm going to close with two two
little insights here and I'm really this
first one especially is right from
Teresa two implications of everything
number one if I I don't really know the
path that's best for me
don't really know
um in the sense of we always have our
life plan
and then life actually happens and then
we remain in a constant state of
frustration because that wasn't the plan
I don't know about you but I'm a planner
I love a good plan and when things go
according to the plan in my life just
keeps like and I'm trying to drive down
the road and we're like taking detours
we're like off in the woods somewhere
you know like oh
now what was what's the wisdom of Teresa
though and of Christ hey God's word to
me would be Brett
I've got you
it's okay this is the path I've called
you to
one way to think of it is have you ever
not gotten a thing you really wanted
only to realize it was the best thing
that ever happened to you not getting it
or have you ever have you ever gotten a
thing
only to be quite surprised at the
reality of it like oh oh wow okay I'm
not so sure about this in any more this
is kind of a lot
um
and only to get down the road a little
ways and realize oh my gosh
I so needed that that was like the best
thing ever
um this is how I've experienced children
in my life and it's it's awesome that
the fifth graders
um or the second through fifth are in
here
because my son Dax is here and I'm
actually gonna talk about his sister
though because she was first born and by
the time she was two years old I
realized well pick your metaphor I
realized I was in over my head that
would be putting it very mildly uh I was
maybe a better one is over my skis
you ever heard that metaphor if you've
ever been skiing and you're hurtling
down a mountain it's very bad if you
find yourself
over going over your skis
very very bad and that's that would be a
good description of kind of how I found
myself with my two-year-old like oh my
gosh because suddenly I was not
I was not in the center of my life my
been like rub for me like what what is
going on just been decentered and
suddenly my whole world revolved around
who
this little girl
and now here's the thing
get a few years down the road
best thing that ever happened to me
best thing that ever happened to me it
seems that Jesus knew exactly who I
needed my children are perfect for me
in all the richness
of that word perfect I mean they're
they're perfect they're beautiful
they're wonderful and they're
challenging
and they've kind of called things out in
me and I've like had to grow up now
um my point is not at all that you know
the kids are the key you know or
something if you don't have kids no no
the point is precisely what's the path
God's called you to
what is it in your life
that you're like oh my gosh this was not
the plan
but what if it's as Teresa said
that we don't actually know the path
that's best for us and we're going to
have to trust Jesus to lead us back to
the father on the path he's called us to
which leads to implication number two my
life in this very moment
not some idealized picture of my life
not some like when I get there then I'm
on the path that God said no no my life
in this very moment is the path Christ
is leading me on in other words
um one way to think of it is that your
life is Holy Ground
every moment someone needs to hear that
tonight your life is Holy Ground
this moment is Holy Ground for you so
what's our call
well just like
um God talked about with his children
who ran away from him our job is not to
run away our job is to keep showing up
and saying yes
yes God I bless it
I bless it
so it's yes yes
to my children
yes to your boring job
yes or maybe you love your job and God
bless you if that's so but you know not
everyone does yes to sending that
encouraging text yes to Leading your
Meetup again yes to attending your
Meetup that's what we call small groups
here again and sharing vulnerably and
honestly which you all love to do right
I mean you it's one of those things
right God's leading you on the path and
you know it's good it's good you know
down the road but sometimes it could be
hard you know it's hard to be our true
selves
yes to your friendships yes to a a
yes to your partner yes to saying oh God
I'm so sorry yes to saying I forgive you
yes to the home
the car the clothes the possessions God
has given you oh in America we're so bad
at that yeah it's always like the next
thing you know
yes yes a thousand times yes this is how
Christ leads us on the path
in the name of the Father the Son in the
Holy Spirit
amen
so tonight as we come to the table of
the Lord
as we take in the body of Christ and the
bread the blood of Christ in the wine
it's a moment
where
a moment of reflection
a moment to reflect on our life and what
God's perhaps calling you to say yes to
a moment of connection
with the one who made you and loves you
perfectly just as you are knows the path
that you need
so the way we're going to do this is
we'll kind of start here at the front
rows and we'll just kind of work our way
to the back by forming just one line
right here we practice what's called an
Open Table meaning if you're here
tonight and you want to participate in
communion you want to connect with the
Risen Jesus
even if you don't have all your theology
or whatever worked out but you're like I
trust enough that Christ is somehow
there and I want to connect with him
then you are welcome to um come forward
regardless of exact theological beliefs
or denominational
whatever
um you're you're welcome here the red is
wine the white is grape juice so fair
warning and
um finally you can partake just whenever
you like so you can you know partake
immediately you can return to your seat
and kind of take but you can just do
that on your own no one will like lead
you through the you know the take
so this is the table not at the church
but of the Lord and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more so come
you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed
come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you
his will
that those who want to meet him should
meet him here come to the table
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
before we close out with this last song
I wanted to read this quick passage it's
out of Romans 7 and kind of in in line
with what Brett was sharing how so often
we're kind of confronted with our own
desires to go a different way than God's
one thing that I love about this passage
is I feel like it is so on to my own
experience and it's Paul in Romans 7 and
he says
I do not understand what I do for what I
want to do I do not do but what I hate I
do for I have the desire to do what's
good but I cannot carry it out for what
I do
is not the good I want to do no the evil
I do not want to do this I keep on doing
when I want to do good evil is right
there with me for in my inner being I
Delight in God's law but I see another
law at work in me Waging War against
Allah in my mind
what a wretch I am who will rescue me
from this body of death
I don't know if anyone else relates to
that but sometimes like you look back on
the moment you just lived and you're
like who was that that just did that
like that isn't that wasn't the plan
that wasn't the reaction I was gonna
have I was gonna be calm cool and
collected or I was gonna forgive or I
was gonna be gracious whatever it is you
know or I wasn't gonna go back to that
stumbling block that I've been living my
whole life you know like why
and I love that there are passages like
this where it's like
ah why what is going on and then right
after that in Romans 8 the first verse
says therefore there is now no
condemnation for those who are in Jesus
and that is the message that I believe
Jesus continues to invite me into where
it's like yeah I know but there's no
condemnation yeah I know you lost it
you're still mine still mine still mine
still mine still claim you still love
you still love you no matter what over
and over and over and over again and if
we could be those kind of Believers for
each other still his you're still his
you're still his and repeat that message
of life for each other for ourselves how
how much more grace would we experience
how much more freedom could we find so
anyway this song is one of my favorites
it's by a guy named Chris renzema look
it up it's called how to be yours Josh
is going to sing it tonight and the
words are just that honest cry I don't
know how I don't know how to do it and
then God is like still mine still mine
so I hope it speaks to you guys you can
just sit back and enjoy this or stand if
you want but
um we're gonna do it anyway either way
[Music]
thank you
say that you love me don't say
that you love me
cause I don't know how
[Music]
to say that you want me don't say that
you want me cause I don't know how to be
yours
[Music]
an orphan I guess
in my heart heart breaks to confess
that even while you hold me it's a cry
on the floor
I still don't know how to be yours
[Music]
you say that you love me don't say that
you love me cause I don't know how to be
yours
you say that you want me don't say you
want me cause I don't know how to be
yours
like an orphan I guess
my heart heart breaks to confess
that even while you hold me it's a
crying on the floor
I still don't know how
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
just love me or hate me I'm not going
anywhere leave me or take me
still bear my signature know me or not
see nor forgotten
King now
on you
[Music]
love me you hate me I'm not going
anywhere leave me or take me
if you'll bear my signature know me or
not
I've seen or forgotten
[Music]
I'm not going anywhere leave me or take
me
still bear my signature
[Music]
now on you
I
ping out on you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you so much for being here with us
tonight and especially to those who this
is your first time to be here we're
especially grateful that you came
if you are new we would love for you to
fill out a card at the tiny little table
out in the hallway on your way out and
this will allow us to follow up with you
and answer any questions that you might
have and also say thank you for visiting
if you are in need of prayer or a hug or
just someone to talk to come find me
after the service I'll be here and
available to help however I can
here at the table we are a community
that is committed to creating an
inclusive community that touches lives
and supports other like-minded
non-profits we believe that generosity
is a key component of building the kind
of community that we envision and we're
so grateful for those who have already
partnered with us
if you would like to consider joining us
in this endeavor you can do that online
at the table
tx.org or at the small box again on the
small table in the front
please don't forget to head over to hat
Creek Burger Company in Sachse for our
first Sunday meal right after the
service
now let me send you out into your week
with this blessing
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
and go filled with the Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts to
everyone you come in contact with
be blessed and have a good night and
we'll see you over at hat Creek thank
you
[Music]
foreign